I gotta ask you I went I took a crazy
trip about two weeks ago to Armenia it's
an episode we're gonna air in a couple
of weeks
I took my assistant to Armenia and I
went through Dubai and then I heard that
you were in Dubai long ago right I was
there for a very short period of time
but it does feel like you're in another
planet
yeah Dubai is I mean it's basically like
Vegas on crack with none of the subtlety
really really overwhelming its
impressive it's very impressive place we
finished shooting the Star Trek film
there we were there for about three and
a half weeks and it just it's
mind-boggling we have the world's
largest yeah they have the world's
largest indoor everything everything
yeah you can go skiing indoors there you
can on a mountain that they've built it
alive yeah it's basically akin to
building an indoor beach in Antarctica
like it makes zero sense that why it
would be there but it's there and also
like you can go scuba diving in the mall
like literally scuba diving you you can
do anything there pretty much did you
you went to a water park we went to a
water park I love a water park anybody
with me I love a water park and they had
an infection I always I always think
about it a water oh absolutely
yeah I never used to think about that
when I was a kid but now that I went
back has like I'm in my mid-30s I was
like oh yeah like a full body band-aid
please but the worst was they had like
the probably the tallest waterslide of
the world but you get in this like like
chamber and there's a ground under you
and then it counts down from three and
then when three happens the ground just
opens and you just fall down and like
it's totally enclosed so you can't
really see where you're going so I was
just screaming and just like basically
drink like it was just I was like oh
you were drinking that water yeah that's
great I'm here to tell about it so I
think it all would have water but yeah I
mean we had a good time it was just
really like the tallest building in the
world the biggest mall in the world
which now they're behind them all
they're excavating the land between the
mall and the Gulf so that people can
literally pull their yachts up to the
mall and get out of their yachts to go
shopping but that's usually how I do it
yeah I take my yacht to the mall put on
my scuba equipment go in
I find the j.crew on your pants I try on
yeah I try on the cargo pants and then
I'm off and this is a hole at the
Glendale Galleria yeah